Now that we've identified what should be
our promoted action, let's create one.
The designs port library implements all
the features one would have to build
into a fab, like touch elevation and
interaction with other elements.
Some features, like ripples, are not
supported in all versions of Android,
even with the use of
the support library.
Depending on when your
project was created, or
what version of Android Studio
you use to create it,
the project might already have some
of the things I'm going to add.
On the other hand, you'll likely come
across a legacy app that you would need
to update, so
it's good to know what to look for.
First you'll need to add these two
lines to your build.gradle file.
I'll explain why we need
appcompat in just a second.
The design library adds
several widgets and
layouts that make implementing
material design much easier.
22.2.0 was the most recent version
at the time of recording, but
use whatever is the latest and greatest.
So here's our definition of the floating
action button that will be in our
layout file.
So as you can see some of these
attributes are on the app namespace, and
some are on Android namespace.
Let's focus on the app ones.
So as Nick mentioned before,
the fab can be normal sized or mini.
This corresponds to 56dp.
Next we have an elevation,
a resting elevation for
our floating action button,
we want that to be 6dp.
One thing that might be
new is layout gravity.
Assuming a left to right layout system,
end is a synonym for right.
So it should lay out the fab to
the right of whatever element or
your layout.
Next is the pressedTranslationZ
property of 12dp, so
when this button is pressed,
we want it to raise to a total of 12dp.
That's followed by a bunch of attributes
here that you've probably already
seen before.
So we're not going to go over
these point by point right now.
Now, if we try to build this right now,
it'll refuse to run properly.
Android Studio will first complain
that there was an error inflating
the floating action button.
That's because the fab needs
AppCompat for style information.
To resolve this last error,
we need to replace instances
of Material with AppCompat.
And then you're all set.
You're fab will elevate and
show ripples when touched.
And you can treat it like
any other button in your UI.